c'est un rendez-vous bien connu des
amateurs d'art contemporain la 4e
biennale versaillaise a pris place
pendant près d'une semaine au sein des
murs du carré à la farine le salon
regroupe plusieurs artistes de tous les
horizons
cette année ils sont soixante dix huit
venus de france mais aussi de belgique à
exposer leurs oeuvres
je fréquente les salons de la région
parisienne des paris les grands salons
d'art gérés par des artistes j'envoie
des candidatures il se présente ainsi
comme plusieurs autres et là dans cette
biennale et l'a1 sordo qui ont été reçus
des représentations artistiques issues
de différents courants tableaux
sculptures gravures au total plus de 140
oeuvres font partie de cette édition
[Musique]
non
pour les tableaux différents matériaux
ont été utilisés acrylique aquarelle ou
encore peinture à l'huile que j'ai c'est
de placer des tableaux -selon les thèmes
qu'ils ont utilisés selon les dimensions
les couleurs pour que ça soit
harmonieuse techniquement des oeuvres à
découvrir et pourquoi pas acquérir
jusqu'au 26 janvier au carré à la farine
à versailles